-Welcome back, everybody,
to "Corrections,"
and let's get started.
We, last week in "Corrections"
I referenced
an O. Henry story.
I did not realize,
O. Henry, of course,
known for writing short stories
that had twist endings,
if you will.
I did not realize that,
O. Henry was a pen name.
Nom de plume,
as Shoemaker likes to say.
His real name, Henry.
And he got his pen name
because he would give
his stories to his wife.
And when she would get
to the twist endings.
She would say, "Oh! Henry!"
A couple of people,
a lot of people
caught the reference
to "The Gift of the Magi.
Two people said, "Hey, you stole
that from the Muppets'
1978 Christmas Special."
Well, this is no. No judgment.
This is a true story.
And I'm going to stop there
a couple of weeks ago,
I said this is a true story
that happened
and a couple of people said,
once you say
this is a true story,
you don't have to say
"that happened"
because that's redundant
and people who watch
"Corrections"
want to keep it moving.
This is a true story --
My dad, every Christmas
would tell my brother and I
a story about Yussi the Yak and
Morris the Moose
who were best friends.
And Morris had
beautiful antlers,
and what he wanted more
than anything was a bow
for his antlers.
And Yussi was a yak
who wanted a brush
for his beautiful yak hair.
And, I think you know
where this is going,
Morris sold his antlers
to get the brush,
and Yussi stole his hair
to get the bow
for Morris's antlers.
One of the reasons
they said a red flag
that this is maybe not
a real story
is that it was
a Christmas story,
and the characters names
were Yussi and Morris.
But the first time --
I can't remember what age --
the first time we were
assigned "Gift of a Magi,"
I read it and my reaction was,
"He stole this from my dad."
and I went up to my teacher
and I had to explain it to her,
and she crestfallen.
Because obviously,
this is an author she respected
and book she'd assigned over the
years, and I'll never forget.
What she said when it dawned on
her that he was a thief.
She said, "Oh. Henry."
I talked about how Shoemaker's
never on camera,
one person said, "Wait, wasn't
Shoemaker on camera
when you showed the picture
of him in a tank top?"
Oop, you've messed up
your Mikes.
We have a Mike Scallions
and a Mike Shoemaker.
They share a name
and they're unpleasant
in very different ways.
[ Laughter ]
When Scallions says,
"Sun's out, guns out,"
its tank top,
when Shoemaker says it,
it's like a snub-nosed revolver.
We talked about Pavarotti.
I called him a B-list celebrity,
people were really upset.
I clarified that
when a person is Italian
the B means bellissimo.
I was also told
you could call him --
It would be very insulting
to call him a C-list celebrity.
But you could,
in opera terms,
you could call him
a high-C-list celebrity.
As that is the note
he was very famous for hitting.
Bird's nostrils
are called nares.
That comes up, obviously,
because.
We keep showing
this photo of the, um,
pigeon.
Can we show the pigeon here?
There we go.
Those are, those are its nares
right there underneath.
Those are the exposed nares.
And what we were told it was
what was really troubling
was that the bricks were in
the wrong going the wrong way.
Some people reached out
and said,
"That's actually
a style of brick."
It's called soldier style
when you do bricks that way.
And then someone else said,
"Bud, I hate to run to
the defense
of your graphics department,
but fully, fully exists
in New York City."
So. The only thing I'll say
is just because graphics
was right on this doesn't mean
they're good people.
[ Laughter ]
Because you show the pigeon
one time.
This is truly what happened.
So let's the pigeon.
And I saw it
and I was frustrated
because people were
criticizing the bricks,
whether right or wrong.
Our viewers criticized
the bricks, and I said,
"Hey, can you just can you
put it on its side?"
And this is what
they sent back.
[ Laughter ]
We also -- this is
a few weeks back now.
We wrote a thing saying
it's like Pete Rose
being on second base,
calling his bookie.
And...
it was a photo of Pete Rose
who didn't play second base,
standing near second base
with a first baseman's glove,
and a lot of people said,
"Hey, what are you doing?
Pete Rose didn't play second and
that's a first baseman's glove."
And the reality is we,
when we wrote it,
we meant that he had doubled
and was standing
on second base
because there's two ways
to do it in baseball.
But unless you are to the word
with the graphics department,
they will [Bleep] you.
[ Laughter ]
And I went down because,
again, I get angry,
I go down, knock, knock, knock,
and they're like, "Come in."
And again, I --
Shame on me for teeing it up,
and I'm like, "Do you guys
not know the difference
between first base
and second base?"
And they're like,
"Oh, no you want to show us?"
And then thankfully we have
we have an HR person
that we've basically
just put in the booth,
the graphics booth,
because like 95 percent
of our complaints
come out of there.
So there's just this guy, Gene,
who just reads
and he's like reading
the daily news
and he's always like,
Hey, cut it out.
And I was burning graphics
on the fact
that we have
a satellite that exploded
and then the pieces fell down,
and in my criticism
then I revealed
I don't know anything
about outer space,
and I said the pieces
wouldn't fall down
because there's
no gravity out there.
There is gravity in space
and the pieces
just wouldn't fall straight down
because of orbital speed
and lateral velocity.
And then someone else
mentioned inertia,
and I thought, that's
a good thing to talk about.
Because, I kind of feel
like at its core, graphics,
I'm sorry, not graphics.
"Corrections" is is sort
of a form of inertia.
In that we're not actually
getting anywhere.
Like this is the act
of getting better,
but I don't, I fear that there's
not any actual --
For example, the Irish
prime minister
came back up again
because you guys,
he was here and I then,
even after having worked
so hard on the pronunciation,
I got it wrong again.
It's Taoiseach.
[Tee shock]
But I even tried last week
to watch, and I made the mistake
because you --
a lot of Irish viewers
have made it very clear
it's Taoiseach
and then I made a mistake
like watching.
You can try to watch YouTube
videos where people say it,
but they're all like really old
Irish men
who are very the way
they tell you, it's like,
[ Irish accent ] It's very easy
to say the word
just push the bottom
of your tongue
against the outside
of your teeth
and press the air
out through your nose,
in your mouth in equal measure.
But don't say
the top part of the T.
Don't say the part
that goes across.
Just do this part.
Just think of
a soldier-style brick.
[ Normal voice ]
Also, someone said, you know,
you don't have to say Taoiseach,
you could just say his name.
Here's the thing,
that's his name.
I think it's a trap
that look super easy,
but something's
going on right there.
There it is.
And I feel like
if I said this the way
I think it is, you'd be like,
it's "Me shock."
He was here and nobody got me.
They'll be like.
"Oh, were you not?
They were doing a table read
of Wedding Crashers 2,
and neither Owen
or Vince were there.
We didn't think to get you."
This is my favorite comment
of the week,
because someone's frustrated.
Just wrote this.
I don't, I don't know.
Tried to call Samberg last week.
He didn't answer.
Pretty upset.
Because when I went to NBC
with "Corrections"
and they gave us
the seed money for it.
The promise was that
I would be able to call
my celebrity friends
and get them to answer.
And, well, you know, what's he
got going on that he can't
answer a phone call from me?
You write down words
that rhyme with nutsack.
[ Laughter ]
So I almost I don't know if I
want to give him another chance.
But at the same time.
You know, I love him.
He owes me.
[ Cell phone rings ]
Nope.
That's how it goes, guys.
It's Bachman-Turner Overdrive.
[ Cell phone dings ]
Not him.
[ Laughter ]
It's Bachman-Turner Overdrive.
So I'm glad we have taken care
of that business.
[ Light laughter ]
Also, the Mets second place --
second baseman
was Wally Backman.
And I'd show a picture of him,
but...
Graphics would probably
put them in a [Bleep]
catcher's mitt
and a football helmet.
We did, um,
a surprise inspection,
where we read jokes
that our writers had written
that were too, did not meet
the standard of the show
and we wanted to sort of
shame them by reading them.
A lot of people wrote,
"This isn't a correction,
but we do feel like Ally Hord's
joke was really good
and you shouldn't
have judged it poorly."
Her joke was,
"According to a new study,
mice have feelings of sadness
and depression.
Asks scientists, 'Did
they say if it was because
of the cancer we gave them?'"
People really liked that joke.
Ian wrote, "In honor of
Disney World's 50th anniversary,
Southwest Airlines has unveiled
a commemorative custom
designed plane that features
an outline
of Cinderella Castle
on the outside,
but heads up the inside
is still full pumpkin."
Not a word of support
for that joke.
[ Laughter ]
I aired, and I was going
to try to burn Ian for it.
I made a mistake
when I said it on the show
and I went back and looked.
I said, Cinderella's Castle
and a lot of people.
One guy said to me,
It's not Cinderella's Castle,
it's Cinderella Castle.
It is not her castle.
It is Prince Charming's castle
named after her,
but she just lives there.
It's not Cinderella's Castle.
She just lives there
at Prince Charming's castle.
And there's one thing
I will say about the guy
who wrote me that,
he's not married.
[ Laughter ]
Because, you know,
I think at some point
it was Cinderella's Castle.
And maybe when she first
moved in, he was like,
So I'm going to name it
after you, Cinderella's Castle.
But, like, no, it's okay.
You know, it's like mine.
You can just live here
and we'll call it
Cinderella Castle,
but I just want to make sure.
And then like a week later,
one of his friends are like,
Did I see an apostrophe
S on the gate?
[ Light laughter ]
My Randy Newman now people
have moved on from Bill Cosby
and said he sounds
like a Jamaican.
[ As Newman ] Get up, stand up.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] I'd like to do
something a little...
I'd like to do something
a little different.
Can we put up a title card,
maybe in a beautiful script?
That says, "Reflections."
And when we put it up,
can we play some
sort of thoughtful music?
[ Fanfare plays ]
Welcome to "Reflections."
We've talked about this.
Monday will be our first show
back with audiences.
We have done 241 shows
without an audience
after we left on March 12, 2020.
And I have a fair amount
of nervousness
and trepidation
about audiences coming back.
I just want to be honest
about that.
I will say that most of of you
who engage
with "Corrections" seem,
to not want the audience back,
which is not super
surprising me
because it always struck me,
that based on the way you are,
you don't like people.
I want to assure you,
the "Corrections" will always be
without an audience.
And...
having an audience back...
is very exciting in the way
that the last --
I know, it's strange to say
these last 18 months
has been really exciting
for terrible reasons,
but we've had all these
different challenges
that we've had to overcome.
And I think one of the biggest
fears when you do a show
like this is that
they're going to be boring.
And nothing about the last
two years have been boring.
I mean, we did it from an attic
and we did it
from my in-law's house
and I was worried
last September.
I was deeply worried
last September
about how the show
would feel coming back
in the studio
without an audience.
And I think it's been
pretty wonderful
and it's been really cool
to have you here
with us in this intimate space.
And I think, you know,
we all know
what Buck's laugh sounds like,
and we all know what
Wally's laugh sounds like.
Still waiting on Paul.
Everybody, but.
I should also stress, you know,
I made some jokes about.
Wally being on the show last.
It turns out we did
not look closely
at the last contract
we signed with Wally,
and there's some
pretty onerous language.
And if he is not on camera,
a fair amount.
He has threatened that
he'll start using white Sharpie.
[ Laughter ]
So the goal,
is to try to take everything
that we've loved
about the last almost two years
of doing this show
outside the way we were
so used to doing it,
for the first six years
of doing this show,
so take that and bring that back
with the excitement
of having a live audience.
That's the challenge
and I think, you know.
you know, there is a expression.
You know. Necessity has a name,
and it is inventor-mom.
And so much of what
has been fun about
this era of the show is things
you have to figure out
because of the hurdles that have
been put in front of us
by circumstance and...
I'm looking forward
to the next part of it.
And I hope you'll
come along with us.
The weirdest thing was,
I never, swear to God,
never read a YouTube comment
about our show
until I started doing it in the
attic, and then I realize now
it's very easy to track.
[ Cell phone dings ]
Nope.
[ Laughter ]
I started reading them
because I was desperate
for some level of feedback,
right,
you do the show
in front of an audience.
You don't walk off every night
wondering how it went.
You kind of in your head,
know how it went,
but you start doing it
in attic and you think,
Oh, I should try to check in
and see how this is going.
And so I waded into what
everyone said was a cesspool,
and I found some very nice
people there.
And I want to.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much for the way
that you've engaged
with this show.
Because we do feel like it's
it's better and it's different,
and we've enjoyed
being on that journey.
And that's the end
of "Reflections"
and if we could just again
do the script
and maybe something that matches
the emotion of the moment.
[ Fanfare plays ]
Lastly, I'd like to close.
Mike Shoemaker's
birthday tomorrow.
And...
It's a bummer because he makes
a huge deal out of it.
I'm of the mind that people
of a certain age should stop
making huge deals
out of their birthday.
Shoemaker is well past that age.
And yet every year, you know,
he rents out some weird room
in the Bronx
that we all have to go to.
It's usually in the basement
of some weird Catholic Church.
[ Cell phone dings ]
And the worst part is he does
the same thing every year,
which is we all show up
and he's not there.
And then they roll
in one of those big cakes,
that, like,
a lady jumps out of.
And every year, it's him,
but he, like, makes us wait
and we have to go through
this whole like weird
like "Where is he?
I don't know where he is."
And he's inside this cake
and like the cardboard.
There's something about
the cardboard or the cake
like it like makes
his allergies really bad.
So he's just you hear him like
[imitates coughing]
Like inside the cake,
just like hacking coughs.
And we all have to be like,
"Oh, I wish he was here.
He's not here on his birthday."
And meanwhile, like,
he can't see us,
we're all just like rolling her
eyes at each other.
And then
and then he pops out like nine
we give you tells us to get
there at 6:30.
It's like nine o'clock he,
like, pops out of the cake.
And he's always like, "Who's
your [Bleep] O. Henry now?"
See me next week.